Final Fantasy 15 s release day 2 may
have been revealed ahead of the official
uncovered reveal event on March 30
komatsu reports that the game will
arrive on Xbox one and PlayStation 4
come September 30 allegedly that
information was backed up by three
different independent sources who
according to komatsu would have
knowledge of the matter the uncovered
event in Los Angeles takes place in a
couple of weeks and it's where Square
Enix were planning to make an official
announcement komatsu explained that our
sources in this case are reliable
however given the sensitivity of the
matter and that within a company setting
anything can change before it is made
public we're reporting this as a rumor
until the release date is officially
announced Final Fantasy 15 was
originally announced in 2006 as final
fantasy versus 13 before was renamed and
shifted over to current gen platforms
we'll keep you updated on this one so be
sure to head over to gamespot for all
the latest